hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome back to doom eternal I am
ready to kill myself some demons did I
want to rip and I want to tear until I
can no longer rip and I can no longer
tear
it will give you strength
help you on your journey interesting huh
all right
ooh you kind of sound like Samuel Hayden
they did say that Samuel Hayden's
technology kind of sounded a little bit
like her is related to it there might be
something there there might be some
connection to Samuel Hayden and whoever
this guy is oh yeah I gotcha all right
so this time we're gonna get into the
beefiest of fights cuz I actually I saw
after this I believe and there was
definitely some fighting Lee had the
divinity machine that's what this thing
is within the infinite conscious matrix
of the all-seeing maker God mind there
exists every potentiality every
predictive variable of the possible
future timeline each one known to the
maker collective with omniscient in
extra Keable clarity the god mind
surveys these timelines watching them
form and expand exponentially like
fractal patterns in the fabric of
existence among these infinite
possibilities only one constant appears
among them unchanged by the flowing data
of endless variability that of the
prophesized destroyer the one who would
bring about the destruction of the
makers well maybe the makers shouldn't
have been such little [ __ ] and decide
to go on being little [ __ ]
can I have you well halfway through the
ground I am I
I'm falling oh the game heard me talking
[ __ ] Oh No
okay we're just doing another pit of
hell whoa hi gonna get you I'm gonna get
you I'm gonna get you I'm gonna get you
look each other see if I lock on just
war I fell and I'm falling interesting
fascinating I did I DC lef and I have
clipped lady iddqd nope okay I think I
got a load of check poking on this bad
boy here just leave it up to me to break
the game it's pretty though very pretty
it's cool to see how it loads
dynamically like that
okay I'm gonna load all right oops no
that doesn't count as a death cuz that
definitely wasn't what that was about
all right here we go Boing ow all right
let's do this I know this one's gonna be
intense
that's not what I wanted to hit whatever
it's all good okay blood punch for you
Oh what the hell
God something it's hard
oh hey bud thank you
whoa that's a lot of dudes BAM mo got
him stuck
oh no that's not ideal wow I don't know
pay for that okay up whoa that was a
module after mud dudes
okay around and around ring around my
Rosie Rosie around my ring there we are
year dunzo
there we go Danzo not bad not bad not
bad
much better than the first time I tried
to do that a while back where as in I
think I only killed like two dudes my
first time something going on over there
just play another secret - I also have
not been using my BFG but mostly because
that's cheating oh there was a secret
over there I gotta go back I also want
to be very clear you know I did have
criticism of the story last time but
don't take that for granted there are
elements of the story that I do like
there are just like elements of
characterization that I take very
personally because I do enjoy the story
as it is well that doesn't describe much
of what I have to do to get that
interesting uh alright then I guess I
will just guess that I am not supposed
to get it yet and I will come back for
it later or something of that Nate well
hey never mind I found you baby I bet
that was the one yeah oh yeah I was one
never mind oh that's what I'm talking
about baby that's what I gave the big
brain for yeah what did that do to do
that I don't know why but I did and I
did that anyway thank you poink oh very
cute very cute very cute yeah there are
elements of the story that I do like I
like the effort to tie in the doom guide
to the original game that's an ambitious
move that's bold move that is a
fanservice move but also it's a
respectable move in just terms of like
trying to make that work they could have
very easily kind of been like that are
two different people and then everyone
I've been like upset in that way and I
get it like I have criticism that's
because I'm a fan like I have criticism
because I care about it and it doesn't
discredit anything else they've done
because of that so just to be very clear
about that long did I get it
I did now the question is what did I get
oh nice yeah I remember the first time I
was playing this this area in the early
access I had to the game and just being
like ooh man I have no idea what I'm
doing but I want that key because that
key is the only thing standing between
me and the unmake er the even more
badass version of the B F G by the looks
of it there's a tunnel off to the left
and maybe to the right yeah there's
definitely a total right then let's just
press on and we'll get to it eventually
rad suit thank you very red indeed gonna
I got a shoot there here we go ma'am I
need a radiation thing or I will sit in
sludge hop-hop poring point alright now
where would someone the likes of me gooo
get down here Oh boom baby yes there we
go man I didn't know I'd have to be
swimming through the sewers to fix our
plumbing situation that's just another
thing that I can put on my resume I
guess man it certainly is good that I
punched those exactly the distance that
they need to be punched and no more long
okay then
bonk that open that and I feel like I
may have missed some kind of a secret
but maybe not
uh-huh uh-huh Oh is it that easy oh it's
that easy
oh it's that easy Oh get me in the
Slayer room I am ready for it give it to
me because I want all of it
I don't care put whatever you want in
there Marauders anything I'll take it
down dude I'm so ready this is the one
that gets me the unmake er oh this is
the one give it to me
hello good oh it's an arch vile huh
well you Wow okay you suck a little more
I knew that was a lot of damage all
right so word to the wise do not charge
an arch-vile head-on but definitely do
take it out quickly whoa whoa where are
you there you are
whoa wolf oh my god cease with all these
like super powerful dudes around
everywhere I just got to make sure I'm
always on my toes with that stuff where
is he
Diaries no not that guy up there right
the guy right in front of me oh my god
we know oh my god
good god ah that freaking arts file all
right it's okay you know what I'm gonna
do this is what I'm gonna do
sorry bud you get to die
oh no you're dead Oh whoa I thought that
was lagging oh this guy's a damn and
sponge oh [ __ ] where did I just go ah
missed whoa okay that's not good okay do
not kill me do not kill me where's
health where's health where's oh my god
where self please where's health please
where's health oh my god
where is health oh my god where's health
there's health Oh a little bit a little
bit a little bit oh yes please oh no
that's not what I wanted I wanted it you
yes yep yes say give me your help I'll
suck it out of you I don't care where I
got a second from I'll suck it out of
you not that guy
thank you yes please I would like this
all right
so I need this because oh it's like
because I haven't taken out this guy's
turret he's just had free reign to mess
with me this whole time
damnit oh no I got it oh sweet
nice shot me thank you me nah not him
not from downtown many a time I want to
go downtown but not that time seems to
be just a bunch of these dudes which is
fine I'll manage with these if this is
what you want to give me I'll take it
who's Zeus teleporting where who's doing
this hello oh you guys you [ __ ] you
dillweeds calm down oh [ __ ] you did not
calm down one down come on what are you
doing what are you doing what are you
even trying to do what are you milk
who's next who's next who's this Oh big
guy [ __ ] what the hell what the hell oh
my god what am I stuck on whoa not like
this dude's not like this you're not
gonna give me like that that's not how
this is gonna go down Oh My gods how
it's gonna go down oh my gosh how it's
exactly gonna go down apparently
nice
look thanks for the lift hello buddy
hello use me thank you
hey I need to do something real quick
thank you this is all kinds of dicey
sorry my dude well that's an interesting
maneuver that's a lot of you guys how's
it doing hey everybody here Wampus put
your hands in the air don't shoot me oh
[ __ ] let me Adam no no he's right there
no God he go and he's is he dead god
dammit you call you robbed me you suck
so much I had that I had it I had it you
robbed me of my glory you robbed me
where are you going buddy all right god
damn it I was gonna I was gonna glory I
was gonna glory would have been awesome
oh well it's fine cuz I got my last key
and that's all that matters and I'm
gonna get myself a nunnemaker
I'm proud of me beating it I'm proud I'm
proud don't get me wrong a quite an
accomplishment I'm incredible I know but
that could have been wonderful could
have been beautiful could have been
something spectacular
hey how you doing stop that stop
you especially stop that stop all that
love of ski
Oh who's here nice oh hey bud oh you're
a big dude
you big whoa you I don't like you guys
stop being so close to me whoa stuck
stuck stuck stuck on what on what on
what oh hello where'd you come from
nice
boom these guys are tough actually i
think i think i saw that these are
actually the only female demons oh is
there an arts trail on the scene i think
there's there's alright where's my gun
where is he where's the artifact there
you are baby
Oh God stop stop stop just die oh my god
what am i stuck on ah no your life how
are you alive
No stop what is happening
I just got bounced back and forth what
was happening I was literally like
booing booing booing booing I could not
break out of it
who is that garbage I was so stupid oh
god damn it really oh you suck
oh but I was right there oh god it's
always like that I've got a special
surprise for the edge file whenever it's
decides to show up
oh it is on the scene huh all right then
oh hey how you doing buddy hey Zia boy
all right cool good doggy
uh-huh turns out that's what I should
have done from the beginning you know I
should use this BFG not be too shy of it
all right
ah there is some way to go up here
there's some way to go through there
right here easy enough pretty
straightforward ooh nice skull don't
know why that's there but that seems to
have some kind of reverent importance
all right so this one
it might be a bit tough to do this one
some kind of low on ammo but I'll just
try to cut down whatever I see first
give me give me give me
oh it's Marauder okay that's that's okay
okay damn it damn it damn it caught just
kill the cat
damn it you
oh my god I've got so little time to
actually kill this guy come on come on
hit me god damn it
oh how are you supposed to be able to
get him in time I could get him with a
BFG shot but that would be risky cuz I
only got so many of those I've done it
before but if I need speed it's gotta be
this alright you know what I'm gonna go
for it big risk big reward am i let's
dance with Stan's puppy let's dance
Oh No
how did not get you
how does not get you are you kidding me
oh man there goes two to be FG amaz that
was a waste I had him
that's so dumb I'm hoping the checkpoint
is gonna give me my ammo back home huh
I've got one shot interesting I'm gonna
do it
what I'm gonna try well that was a
mistake Oh what no no way
come on come on
[Music]
they're all [ __ ] did I do it what he's
dead it's cuz of the glory kill wasn't
it God screw your face I got that are
you kidding me number one I be FG Tim
and number two what the [ __ ] all right
here we go hold fashion style let's do
this
I know come on do something oh my god do
something oh my god
do something how do you how do you get
out of the freeze I guess maybe the
freeze doesn't even affect him it's
giving me another shot with his BF GMO
now that was up that was a perfect Miss
a swing and a Miss come on oh it's too
late now god damn it I killed him I'm so
frustrated with that
[Music]
[Music]
there we go there we go there we go -
yes yes baby all right you were dead
before I must have been like a point
second off before but now he's dead and
he's dead legitimately I didn't even try
to use the BFG that time that would have
been probably stupid anyway that's like
a once-in-a-lifetime hit and I got that
on my demo play and probably because I
was lucky more than anything all right
let's get back into the real game I only
got one more secret encounter to do in
this area so I guess I'll kill it again
you know I guess that's how that's gonna
work
history is sentinels part 11 yet has the
Slayer in nights sentinels battled the
demonic hosts their failure to act
outside the confines of their duty
allowed the rancor of the essence to
grip the argenta it was on a mission
deep within the boiling seas of the
nether realm where the order of the six
reside that accompany of night sentinels
learned of the kaan makers true dealings
with the Dallas beasts I make a design
it was kept secret from the Sentinels in
argent people alike that the essence we
had grown so relying on during this war
was comprised of the very spirit of our
brothers and sisters who had fallen to
these vile creatures the truth had been
uncovered that all beings who found
their end by the demonic horde would
become a vassal of the hellscape their
flesh in time twisted into the very
demons we fight their souls extracted to
create the essence that powers their
world and ours the victims were the
enemy and the enemy would become us the
soldiers stood in awe at the base of a
factory dedicated to such action a place
where the bodies of the slain were
sorted in processed tortured for the
mill to have their souls extracted
through sinister magic enormous vats of
pain and suffering
ethereal energy the haunting sounds of
lost souls awash in an eternity of
servitude
transformed into energy to power our
struggle against the dark realm and its
malice but worse than this grim reality
was the discovery of the machinery which
was used to enact the vile process our
fallen had been subjected to for it was
not by hoof and claw that this
blasphemous technology had come to pass
by the hand of the Argenta guided by the
mother God's desires we had fallen deep
within the grasp of the enemy away had
fought against would not reveal itself
to be true as without countenance we
could hold no sway over the Argento
populace regardless the honor of the
nine sentinels would have to hold up the
Verity of these claims and the mother
God could be our divinity no more in
secret corridors and clandestine
conference the night sentinels would
find those amongst them who similarly
distrusted the essence and had foretold
the swelling corruption once the truth
could be shared the skeptics became
members of The Sentinel insurrection
Sentinel insurrection in the breach
between holy and unholy agenda began to
grow alright interesting ok quite
fascinating I would say this guy died
nice codpiece sure does look like he's
got a dick balls but what would I know
about demons am i right everybody I am
right off oh hello
may I don't mind if I do
okay so how many crucibles are there by
the way your vote should contain what
you need my vault I have a vault you say
blood punch goddamnit
there we go
what am I stuck on god dammit what what
[Applause]
Rankin's does not get stuck on things
that be the greatest gift any uh if I
could not get stuck on walls where's it
goddamn dude that I can crush where is
whoa whoa what the that's not there I
have no ammo for that where is it there
you you come back come back there if we
go my god this is where a dude make
feisty man is gonna come up oh my god
whoa what the [ __ ] what's up give me up
the goddamn oh my god
you're nothing chump chump whoa way
sorry bud yep you gotta go okay all
right got a little uh got a little
heated that one there
just let the the the rage get to me for
a moment didn't mean to do that I'm all
good I'm good baby I'm good don't worry
about me I'm good I'm good baby all good
here so good how do you know about all
this seriously how do you know about all
this I really question how you know
about all this because it doesn't seem
like it makes much sense that you would
[Music]
and those are good now that I know to
hit him in there but awful alright got
that now to go over here with completely
full health and armor you'll love to see
it you'll love to see it and when you do
see it haul boy it feels good all right
we're about reaching the limit of where
I played in this particular early access
well hey how you doing whoa oh god out
sorry can you swallow this thank you
but okay can you swallow this and I'm
also gonna do this just for good measure
oh god oh you're not you're you're a big
guy
and there you go nice heart I'm good to
see you wouldn't want to be ya hello
I like time for napalm belch longer
flames and a health food boost isn't the
worst thing in the world thank you oh
right history of the Sentinels all right
the truth could not be denied the unholy
spires raised in the barren lands
functioned by blessing of maker
machinery the Kahn had betrayed argent
DeNooyer and had made concert with the
demons to harvest their essence in
return granting them access to all the
worlds under her influence that's cool
now I've got motivation now I understand
a symbiotic relationship had formed
darkness now had been balanced by a
light for where there was heaven so
there would be a hell that's mandatory
the followers would be granted passage
to a deck and the sinners would fall
into the fiery pits of the dark realm
this word would be spread from all
cultures in all worlds and in all places
we were not without blame for it was our
people the priests and Sentinel
engineers who'd laid the work in place
our gentes slaves had built the dark
factories and our own ancient rafe
energy helped purify hells elixir into
the miracle fuel that now powered the
makers world and our own the night
sentinel spoke of the evil brought by
the essence and carried their word to
all who would listen we had helped to
create this new dichotomy and so it must
be for the Argenta to stop the spread of
this pestilence this new phase of
existence the dark and the light if not
for us then for the innocent whose
worlds have yet to fall under the spell
of the maker God and our unseen allies
in the Hell dimension even when the
night sentinels returned from the
demonic realm with tales of slave
factories that damned the souls of the
innocent the indoctrinated masses of
Argentine or
- no quarrel with the makers they were
indebted to the demon essence the
minister is deliberating but finding no
basis for change the messengers were
cast down for daring to speak against
those who have gifted us so much our
gods
the makers in their infinite wisdom
would see fit that the faithful continue
life a new winner dak they feared the
wrath of the mother God a lifetime of
servitude would not be undone by this
resurrection this was simply another
trial a test of faith to identify those
that were truly worthy to experience
life eternal in her dak the Argento
would not waver in their resolve the
night sentinels prepared for war once
again though this Battlement drawing the
blood of their own brothers our army had
seen the work of the demons firsthand
and knew its evil they had returned to
the way of the wraiths and though their
armament was diminished without the
essence it remained pure and righteous
division amongst the Argenta had
occurred one side standing in opposition
to the doctrine of the makers and the
other locked in belief the ascended
Empire was comprised of the faithful and
misled wielding the desecrated energies
of Hell the power of the makers and
Marauders who had sided with the con the
night sentinels were bolstered by the
free people of Argenta and the mightiest
of all killers the Slayer himself plans
and tactics were drawn the Sentinels
would close the Argent factories in the
crow Ville that which fed the world
third act directly with its supplies of
fresh essence they would stop the flow
the slumbering race would wake from this
sleep and give argent DeNooyer courage
oh well that's a lot to take in so I'm
not gonna worry about too much right now
no I'm gonna get back to killing you
know how I like oopsy poopsy I didn't
oopsy poopsy where is that oopsy poopsy
Oh No Oh No oopsy poopsy Oh oopsie boobs
you know
oh I'll have to come back for it when I
can fast travel I think I don't think
I'm gonna be able to get back up there
alright I'm going for it what do we got
in here
hello I spy with my little eye something
swinging a bowl nice alright well that
was nice hi how you doing
good to see I love these gun-based doors
really makes things interesting
ooh oh okay
got him Merilee a challenge guns and
light this culture knew what was up
hello hi hello
[Music]
who should we go for years the civil war
raged and took its toll on the soldiers
as their armor laid stained with the
blood of their brothers on a cursed
battlefield finally an opportunity to
end the war had been discovered by the
order digue in the night sentinels with
the Slayer at the head of their army
they gathered the traverse through the
gate and Sunda necro Ville the city of
the Dead the order of the digue the high
priest who had pledged their allegiance
long ago to the night sentinels worked
in service of our mission those holy
priests who had served the argenta since
time immemorial assured us that the way
was clear plan was set to march into the
accursed walls of the necro wall and
smite the factory cutting off the flow
of s instead a canned denying the con
maker of her prize our forces took spear
in hand and advanced and it is there
that the venom of treachery struck upon
entry through the hel portal the night
sentinels were scattered to the winds of
unplanned chaos our warriors were
separated our ranks split as the gates
twisted and hurled them across the
unholy realm some of our warriors
appeared near through the gates they had
walked before but found that the vile
priests had barred the way back then the
trap was sprung and each lone Argenta
found himself set upon by bloodthirsty
multitudes of demonic beasts let it be
known that it was not the priests alone
who failed the northern army one of the
Sentinels own hell found his weakness
and Exploited it it who the demise of
Argentine or if not for the betrayer
stroke of madness the race power would
still be our own and the Sentinel flag
would still rise above argent DeNooyer
to this day so there were two betrayals
I'll clear that up later flavor
later later later on the clearing up of
that ooh what is this all about it's a
little red coin I'll take that
apparently oh yeah this makes sense
okay just dissolve that into there and
I'm assuming that did something I don't
know what but it did something hi oh hi
I got a punch it okay okay oh I see okay
I see I see what's going on here I see
okay oh oh hey hey good to see you oh
that's handy-dandy
maybe just handy and dandy enough to get
me to be able to jump oh yeah oh yeah
here comes Doug um sorry about your
priceless architecture looks like I
don't give a flying hootenanny
alright something's up there oh I see
you I see you oh boy oh yeah Oh Ray's
rage indeed I need to go down yes I as
you doing retrieve your crucible I
thought I already did
isn't that the thing the sword isn't
that the whole whole idea rad suit why
do I got to keep going in sewers man
alright thank you
whoa what the hell all right down I go I
guess whoomp
all right cool good this is great why is
it so irradiated in this place donk
ha ha ha huh dudes an out-of hit
sometimes I forget that just plain old
firepower is all I really need
hey sometimes I guess I need a little
more than plain ol firepower whoa you
you you you you you you mmm that looks
fancy
that looks really fancy all right
interesting doing uh-huh uh-huh oh here
we go hello what's up here hi
got him Adam Adam whoa hey buddy hey
buddy hey buddy hey buddy
hi bud
whoa here you going buddy where are you
going come on now oh that was gonna be a
big boomy I am out of ammo RNA how about
whoa who's there ai ai ai ai yay oh I'm
backed into a corner and I going over
your head Hey oh no fuel huh oh I'm not
for long there we go
trying so desperately to get a gory kill
so that I could actually get some gosh
darn blood punch energy going on but
also if I had just stated full I
wouldn't be in it worrying about that at
all is this the last history of the
Sentinels it is the very last one
scattered in hell abandoned by their
clergy and reinforcements the Sentinels
prove their worth in what would be their
final war with the forces of evil
unrelenting power in the face of certain
death the Sentinels crushed hundreds of
demons and skewered Titans when they're
at lands held no more fuel the Sentinels
took to the ground and fought the swarms
on land all of Hell knew of the betrayal
for it was without question the makers
in the priests would sowed the seeds of
deceit long before the brave warriors
pass through the gate what hell saw that
day was the beating heart of the free
people of Argentina they did not flinch
in the face of their own certain death
they died as they lived with sword and
shield in hand heard act too low a place
to house such Giants theirs would be the
fate of warrior gods remembered for all
time Lord sash the star word Banner
Sergeant was found with his war standard
pierced through the throat of a great
beast his body surrounded by the corpses
of enemies groan the mighty the light
faded from his eyes had it Visser ated
such a multitude that their entrails
clung to the black rocks like veins Gore
relentless until the end had broken his
blade on the backs of his foes and by
the time he fell he had slain another to
score with his hands
the priests believe the Sentinels all
slain we are Argenta born to overcome
rumors deemed heretical by the order D
persist and claim that the Slayer
himself still rages in the unholy realm
none who live can know for the future of
art and dinner has been bent and twisted
by the perverted vision of the essence
drinkers never again will the light of
the Wraiths illuminate our world all has
fallen if the Slayer does live let him
carry our vengeance forward if he
persists let him rican saan those who
have wronged us may the blood of his
sword never dry may his war never end
until the guilty have been punished and
may this evil never again spread its
shadow over another world ok that's that
then that is that that's that that is
the entire history of the Sentinels lots
of wordy words lots of story time and
leads me to a lot of killing I'll have
thoughts at the end of the game I don't
want to own up bogged down with it too
much I want to get to the action ooh
what am I doing here
ah I'm recharging that makes sense okay
okay I hope we're not leaving right now
I've got to go get things I got to go
get one more thing from this level I
don't want to have to go through it all
over again
ooh The Crucible is a weapon of
extraordinary power press Vita unsheath
then press mouths one to cleave okay oh
I miss come on
oh there he goes whoa whoa what one hit
kills oh yes oh yes oh yes oh yes okay
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah okay sure
thanks for setting up this arena
apparently
oh my god I'm homestead I wasn't paying
attention okay
oh you all right apparently that's how
this is gonna be arts filed dead
squashed no arts filed dead oh is that
all I get
oh come on let me let me play some more
mom I want to slice and dice more I
guess I shouldn't waste on these scuzz
here
okay that was something all right I got
to go back for one last thing so I'm
gonna go do that I gotta get to though
there's two secrets there's one over
there too that I didn't get
oopsies let's try right here did I not
get the autumn app either I didn't get
the autumn app either I am an idiot
turns out I'm big dumb that automap
would have been incredibly helpful in me
finding all this stuff in this place but
I didn't do it cuz it turns out all
right for this one I'm just gonna I'm
gonna be FG the tank dude cuz I don't
have the time or the patience to deal
with them I'm gonna try to actually be
FG everybody oh you're that did not kill
you did it and I come back tonight there
we go
oh do not do not toss me through the
world again oh I thought it was about to
toss me through the world again I was
gonna be very upset okay
so I got that then there's a sentinel
battery right there how do I open you
there's gotta be a secret switch on one
of these doodads I bet I bet I bet oh I
see oh
[Music]
okay I got this dude no I need to go to
the throne room I think there's
something like on a platform here
somewhere in between these two oh god
damn it oh there it was but it was
closed so it's like right oh I just got
a dash through it okay it's got a dash
at the right time
got it oh there we are pain elemental
oof all right so there's just a sentinel
battery left that I gotta get there's
just got to be a switch that opens up a
door somewhere so somewhere on here
there is a switch that will open up that
door so I can get that battery I just
gotta find where that switch would be
and look for the green it's in the green
somewhere there's green this is green
what is that dude green green green just
gotta look for the green green baby
green big green green on the green green
on the grass green grass green fields
there's green somewhere it's gonna open
one of these right up it's gonna open er
up as soon as I see it soon as I see it
as soon as I know it I'm gonna know what
I'm gonna see it I'm gonna see it I'm
gonna know it I'm gonna know it when I
see it and I see it when I know it is I
know when I see it and I know when I see
things and the things that I see are the
things that I know and I know I see the
things that I think I know and I don't
even think that I think I know I know
that I know and I think that I think but
when I think about what I know and I
know what I think I know that I think
that I know where it is you know what I
mean yeah you know exactly what I mean
okay I'm looking it up oh my god ah
hi there was that was really freakin
obscure okay that was well hidden I knew
it was a button somewhere in here man I
do not know how I would have known that
without looking it up okay a No
bunch where am i where'd I go
all right and squabble ah we're done
done baby done baby done baby done sick
alright so now that I did that and
whatever the hell I did to get to
wherever the hell I was hey let me
through I just gotta jump down yes
apparently hi I didn't need to do that I
just felt like doing that okay I got it
wait whoa oh oh oh oh stop hammer time
I'm still missing two secrets how many
goddamn secrets are in this level I have
the map now so you'd think that it would
show them on the map but apparently not
what else is here what else could
possibly be here
oh hi dude oh wow you were not on my map
both of them are here how did you not
show up on my map
dude I was wonder okay o morado boy oh
you were just gonna be secret secret
okay now I've got everything now I can
leave God that took like another 30
minutes oh my god you guys didn't see it
but I was wandering all over the place
just desperately trying to find these
things but I got him
super completionist about it cuz that's
how I operate and now I'm gonna get the
hell out of here and I definitely have
everything and I'm good to go
alright good we there we go what didn't
I get in the challenge uh-huh Oh pain
elementals yeah yeah I didn't get a
chance for that oh that's tasty
whatever oh that is why you must bring
Vega through the void with you to her
understood I'm detaching myself from the
ships systems
processing total transfer to external
drive complete okay there is no longer
connected to your ship
I will reconfigure the portal to Nick
Rahall for you
okay thanks Sam do you welcome to
explore the fortress until your mission
is complete once you're ready to leave
configure the transporter well you know
what buddy what how long has that been
there wait what the hell wait wait a
minute I would have noticed that I
definitely would have noticed that i
100% would have noticed a giant spinning
question mark I absolutely would have
noticed that right I'm not crazy right
maybe this is just gonna be the
exploration and cleanup episode or I get
all this stuff that I've missed over
time so if I was a little secret up
there I would be accessible from events
that would lead somewhere but let me get
the unmake er first let me do that let
me do the fun stuff hi hi yes it's time
Oh oh my goodness oh my word Oh unmake
er is a devastating rapid-fire weapon
with a widespread on maker shares a MoU
with The BFG press F to swap between the
BFG and unmake staggering you say how
staggering are we talking about here I'm
wasting it but whatever yeah they got
layaway better than The BFG all right so
now I gotta figure out how to get to
this goddamn question mark how do we do
it I'll look it up ah I never in my life
would have noticed that
never would I whoa where am i what what
oh thank you I never would have noticed
that there is no way I ever would have
noticed that in the history of anything
that would not have been noticed all
right good to know hey got that all
right so apparently also that one wasn't
available until we got to about this
point the base what how many other
things just appeared in this base
randomly in the intermediary here also
what is this big thing for confusing hi
oh it's just another dude over here well
I mean how many send the old batteries
do I have nine I should probably use
them I should definitely use them huh
hmm
okay
gonna bypass that one so that I can get
that right away okay I might as well
what else am i using them for hi thank
you
there's a little brofist before we get
going all right we got that um okay
what the hell is nother secret what what
what what do you mean secret there's no
secret what it's secret it wasn't a
secret I already knew what it was I only
knew what it was it was plain as day and
sabot I thank you I'll take that
don't mind me carry on all right so I
got those must have been that upgrade
that I got that just reveals all the
things on the things um with that being
said though I think all I need to do oh
that's a you trick to be you tried to
trick me I didn't like that I didn't
like that at all yeah I just got to get
the last of the UM oh not down not down
not down not down I didn't want to go
down what how do you go up oh it's up
there god I didn't want to go down I
didn't want to go down why is this the
only elevator in the game that I can
move around on thank you another one for
the collection I'm not sure I'm gonna
put this good to use my friend I don't
know if I will I cannot promise that I
will at all
all right so those four new suit points
which I'm gonna spend very unwisely you
all right got that all right cool
now I think that should be everything in
the base that I need but what I need to
do before I go and do all the final
level stuff apparently if I'm there I
didn't know I was there but I got to go
back and do some other things from
survivor cells across the globe are
confirming that at some time within the
last 24 hours
demonic invaders have begun amassing and
swarms near gore nests it's not good arc
scientists have theorized that this
behavior is indicative of the arrival of
a super predator a world-eater what park
personnel advise all survivors remain in
the safe cells what else would they do
okay
so I've gotten every single thing from
the past lots of missions except the
first three I didn't do the first three
so what I should do is I should go back
there and get him real quick if I can
which I think I can let's go back to
hell on earth and if the fast travel
option is there which I think it will be
I should be fine unless I gotta play
through the whole thing again that's
gonna take a while let's see what
happens
oh god no really I gotta do it again oh
oh my god hi look you are not looking
forward to this encounter oh I missed a
secret right from the beginning oh my
god I do not have time for anything for
anyone
oh hi okay well that was how did I miss
that the first time oh yeah because I
didn't even know how to punch that's how
I missed it because I was dumb from the
beginning
zombie toy love it good great love it
love that this will take me no time
speed run speed run baby okay hey what's
going on here
I should have turned on a cheap coat or
something would have been more fun skip
I know I got his head
whoa Here I am hey but this is gonna
suck for you bud
BAM okay so there's one up here
up here it's definitely one up here up
here here here we go oh there can only
be one all right I got that one uh
that's the last one for a while so I'm
just gonna scoop the Malou all right
good hey bud whoa hey come back here you
I said oh my god you suck oh my god stop
hitting me yes come down here to my
level
uh-huh uh-huh funny I already have that
weapon this is gonna take a lot longer
than I thought I thought it was just
gonna be an in and out it would give me
the fast travel but no I gotta I gotta
do it all over again there's another
secret ahead that I missed fine been
such a fool the first time around I
wouldn't be in this mess okay there so
how do I get there is the question oh
wait what sighs just something I was
just up there god damn it oh I didn't
miss you lady it did not miss you oh the
wall duh
poop gotcha oh the Qt be no way to
impede beauty all right what else do we
got there's two missing way of course
towards the end okay I got it
I mean this is kind of ridiculous at how
much easier it is I mean yeah I know I
have this super shotgun and whatnot but
that's really the only difference
between me and then it's like experience
the - super shotgun and well I guess a
lot more health in ammo but this is like
laughable I guess at the beginning it
was just basic [ __ ] enemies really
nothing challenging to him I mean the
only thing challenged the only thing
challenging was really the spider dudes
and even they are no longer that big of
an issue that's it I just flipped it on
us took us that makes sense
somewhere here right above me uh-huh ah
I see I see I see I see I see ah miss
this before and I remember climbing on
that and I was like oh maybe win Finny
lives yes on off cheat codes okay oh how
did I miss this that was so basic just
deep nighloks I don't even care about
Deeb nighlok's
who cares it's just Dicky boy but that
was it that was it that was everything I
got everything cool I don't even care
about doing the challenges done there
wasn't even a challenge alright so that
was that level haha
alright return to campaign accept yes I
think I think for the next one I'm gonna
use a cheat code and I'm gonna make sure
that I maybe there's one that's like
super speed that'd be nice and then I
wouldn't have to be bogged down by the
same crap okay so exult yeah what did I
miss here two toys how did I not get the
toys such a fool technically I didn't do
the challenges on some of these but then
again I don't really care about that I
wonder if our cheat codes okay activate
all cheats infant lives Sentinel armor
all runes infinite ammo wedding mastery
overdrive onslaught sure yeah Miam see
what happens
wait okay before I do this let me see
something I think I
all the chica whoa well I was fast all
right there's one thing I want to do
before I do anything else I want to make
sure I think it's over here yeah okay so
my collection is not complete with that
collection is complete though ooh and
this collection is not quite complete I
didn't think I was missing that many
toys that's a lot of empty shelf space
weird all right Commander Keen hey there
he is okay
ah but the cheat codes you have 9 of 14
installation discs 9 of 14 Oh what the
hell
Oh weird ok so I must not have all the
cheat codes so I this last level must
have some of them is the thing well this
must not be the last level then because
I doubt there would be 5 on the last one
here probably would be something more
than that
that bunny where are you binkies where
are you binky binky hey binky are you
doing big guy all right so what I'm
gonna do what I'm gonna do is off-screen
I'm gonna go and collect the things from
the base because that's gonna take like
an hour and I don't want to make this
file size bigger than it already is for
lik C and sake so sorry lik seeing about
the giant file in this one I've been
recording for like over two hours now
well not quite just about two hours now
but yeah I'm gonna do that off-screen
that I'm gonna come back we're gonna
start this next mission and we're gonna
go into this it's gonna be awesome so
thank you everybody so much for watching
let me know what you thought down in the
comments below
now as always I will see you in the next
video bye bye
[Music]